um so shall i get right into that
because today we have a
bear presentation me and uh dorian are
going to
explain you about how we battled covet
using generative
adversarial networks um and since you
guys
of gareth told me you guys like code we
took a very goat-first approach
and we highly we want to highlight one
of the
libraries that we used in that which is
sacred for
machine learning experimentation uh
collecting so but let me first tell you
a bit about
who we are actually so uh
first that's me and dorian dorian you
will do his own introduction later which
you can maybe already see
i've seen him in a video feed me myself
my introduction is i studied computer
science at the theory i was the first
generation of uh people that
were able to do the data science and
engineering master and during my uh
bachelor's i already got heavily
involved with the education
surrounding the tv and i got
really interested in this data science
concept especially since
the department of computer science and
mathematics was really jumping on this
so as a student advisor i helped setting
up the first few
masters and bachelors in data science in
the university of eindhoven but also in
tilburg and
in temples the tilde master that dorian
was able to follow after that so that's
a nice flow of
students there i've worked in a software
company for
two and a half years where i set up the
data science department
and i was actually surprised with
how large the difference was between my
data science skills i learned the
university and what i needed in real
life right
a lot of you will know that there is a
lot of
well data cleaning involved domain
expertise
just working with servers ssh etc
as a computer scientist from background
for me that was
quite okay but during my work i also
noticed with students that didn't have a
formal computer science background but
did specialize in data science
but they were missing a lot of like the
hands-on practical skills of coding and
using servers and using git
so a bit from that frustration i started
playing
with uh the ceo of free punch buster
about how can we close this gap right
and he was already setting up fruit
punch as an organization
so the problem that we're trying to
solve as fruit points is
there's just a lack of good ai engineers
so this is known by everybody
they aren't learned how to use apply how
to apply
data science in the real world it's
basically just learning python notebooks
and learning how backprop how you can
write a back propagation
in pure python which is uh
very important to know but not a very
usable skill though
uh and also this way ai is just not
getting its maximal impact right if we
are teaching people
the wrong way and we're not teaching
people at scale then
we're not never going to close this gap
and it's not going to have the impact
that it can
so that's actually the vision of fruit
patch we want to solve humanity's
greatest challenges
by educating the next generation of ai
engineers at scale
and also redefine how they solve these
problems because
we focus only on ai for good meaning
that
all the ai that we build we want to
connect to
one of the sdgs so one of the
sustainable development goals
so with that we're building the platform
for ai talent development
so how we do this is actually mostly
through
challenge-based learning and
peer-to-peer learning so we're setting
up a community
currently about a thousand people from
all
inhabited continents and our main way of
education would
be our ai for good challenges so when we
want to do an ai for good challenges we
look for organizations
ngos companies universities that have a
data challenge so they basically need to
have a data set
and a problem that they really want to
solve so we
transform this into ai for good
challenge
and we crowdsource a team of engineers
from our community to solve that
challenge we take this into a two month
or uh two month to half a year format
where we try to first get
get the domain there we do some master
classes on the domain specific
technologies but also on the domain
itself
we teach the people the basic skills to
get
for example the high performance
computing ready and all the
the basics that come before you can
solve such a challenge
and then the team just starts challenge
based learning right
they communicate with the stakeholders
they communicate with each other they
learn from each other and that is how
we do the things we do
we all try to skill this through a
platform so we already have a platform
right now
which you can find on footpaths.ai but
we're actually building our own uh
challenge based learning platform where
we also
do a real a gamified learning
journey for everybody so if you join our
platform for the first time
you'll be able to file hey these are my
basic fighting skills these are my beta
basic data science and my basic ai
skills and from there
the system will advise you and okay i
would follow these courses join these
challenges do this mooc and this way you
can build your own profile in a really
gamified way
but the most important thing that we do
so what we do in that session
is accreditate your skills and this
accreditation is
purely peer-to-peer i'm not on a uh
[Applause]
authorized how do you call it
um so what basically happens when a
university gives you a diploma
that's like an authority argument right
so the university
of eindhoven is renowned as being a good
technical university
me having a diploma there makes that you
trust me because the university says
that i'm good
but that doesn't really prove any of
your single skills so if you uh
join in the challenges that we organize
as fruit punch
you actually collaborate with the whole
theme and that this team
will appear to peer review each other
and at some point
these peer-to-peer reviews will actually
prove okay this guy
has the most solid python refactor
skills but this guy has the most solid
generated adversarial skills and this
way you build your own profile which is
actually hard accreditated without an
authority argument in there
but well that's what we do uh um one of
the
as i mentioned the most important thing
that we organize are these ai for good
challenges
and for one of those we got this really
nice team which you see
on the left here this is uh dorian and
esteem
dorian on the left and what they did is
they
uh trained generated adversarial
networks to help
in uh covet diagnosis but
i'm not the expert here dorian is so
that's why i asked him to join in on
this uh
presentation as well so i'll uh stop
sharing my screen and allow him to take
over
thank you for the introduction all right
so this is me i'm dorian
and uh this is our team and
this is braum he was our project leader
we have yari mirta and mirta
and jans and for the last half year
we have been working for fruit punch ai
to
put our ai skills for good
in the ai for health project segmenting
x-ray images
of the lungs using a conditional
adjective network
so what are we talking about if we're
talking about segmentation
well here's a good example uh
where first you have an x-ray image and
a radiologist
often needs to segment this image in
order to
find good diagnosis so what they do
they have an image of a person's lungs
they have to
draw out by hand the edges of the lung
it comes up with the mask and you can
lay it over and
it makes it easier to come up with a
diagnosis
this is a quite a time-consuming
activity
especially now during the covey
19 pandemic this is
uh yeah not very efficient there's a lot
of things these radiologists could be
doing
in the meanwhile as in consulting
patients or
other things that would have been
yeah more highly valuable so we wanted
to create an
a machine learning model that was able
to do this
segmentation and apart from the
diagnostics it's also important that if
you would like to
train a model to classify covid or
classify
other types of lung diseases
it is important that your model will be
trained only on what's happening
inside the lungs so for example on the
first image you can see here little
medical device
if someone's in the hospital and they
want to take a picture or an
extra image then they often have these
kind of devices
on top of them which could trigger a
machine learning model into thinking
that this patient has covered even
though it didn't even recognize anything
inside the lungs
so that's why it's important um
yeah it's very good to implement this
in hospitals nowadays
because due to the covet 19
pandemic mandatory that
all new admitted patients go through an
x-ray screening first before they
are allowed on their uh yeah inside the
uh yeah when they're where they need to
go inside the hospital
um yeah this takes a lot of time from
radiologists and we would like to
uh take over with ai so
they can spend their valuable time in a
lot of better ways
so take off part of their workload and
optimize this
with ai but to train an ai to classify
let's say kovit it is important that
they have the
right input data and data that has been
segmentated
the youth is very it's more easy for a
model to
be able to recognize only what is
happening inside the lungs
so that's why it's important and the way
we wanted to do this is with a hum
or in our case a con can
a conditional adversarial network for
image to image translation
and this is a short schematical
schematic image of how our model
looks so the difference between
a hum of a cat again and a 10 so
a generative versus conditional is that
the generative model
takes in a random input vector and our
conditional model takes in a input image
so it's not a random
vector well then
our can access of two models
we have our generator model and our
discriminator model
and they work together to get a
highest possible performance so yeah i'm
just going to walk it through
we put in an image into the generator
the generator comes out
with a generated mask which is
fed into the discriminator model
together with
real mass then this discriminator model
is strained on that data to classify
whether a mask
is real or fake and this binary
classification is then passed back into
the models
to gain performance
furthermore our generator is
built up from a unit which is
often used in segmentation of a medical
data
and this consists of a a couple encoder
layers
and decoder layers and our discriminator
is a
pretty basic cnn that's classified as
real and fake
so here it gets a bit more technical
so here is how our generator model looks
first we take an input image it is
passed through seven encoder layers
until it reaches a bottleneck layer
which is also a convolutional layer
and then goes through seven decoder
layers
until it's a convolutional transpose
layer
which then uh with a sigmoid activation
creates a mask but now what is special
about this convolutional network
and why this is called a unit is because
for each encoder layer it
takes out the information and also
passed it through
to the uh mirrored decoder layer
and concatenates that with the
information that has come through the
bottleneck
so um yeah here you can see a bit how
these
encoder and decoder layers are built up
the encoder layer is actually pretty
simple
it only exists of a convolutional layer
some batch normalization and activation
leaky relu
and our decoder layer is existing of the
convolutional transpose layers
some batch normalization out if uh
yeah if we want that so experimented
with it a little bit
and then after that a concatenate layer
where it
takes in the
information that's coming through
through the
bottleneck but it also takes in the skip
information
which is uh coming from the encoder
directly
and the reason why it does this is it it
can take a lot more
information until the
last layers
yeah here you can see how their
generator is defined
but in code so what we just saw in this
in this scheme
so first we whilst pass our image
through the
encoder blocks we start off with small
filters
uh going up bigger and bigger and bigger
so downsizing our model or our image
until we reach our bottleneck then
we pass this through to the decoder
model which then takes this information
from the bottleneck but also from
our last encoder bottle uh encoder block
and then uh up samples are image again
until it gets to the activation
point where we get a sigmoid uh
activation where we get ones and zeros
for each pixel
and then you can see how a input will
result
in a certain output for
updating this model we use the mean
squared error and binary cross
entropy on a yeah with weights of 100 to
1
and yeah with the sigmoid activation
which i already told
we also uh now now we come to the
discriminator
this one is a little bit easier to
understand
it's it has six convolutional layers
it comes up with a input image
so the x-ray image of the lungs end with
a
fake or real mask and then concatenates
these two
pulses through convolutional layers and
batch normalization layers
and leaky reality activation until it
reaches a point
where it is defined if it's a real or a
fake image
and this discriminator is then trained
with the binary cross
entropy function or loss function
so that is a bit how our generator and
our discriminator
uh uh work but now it's
ideal if they if these two are working
together
to create an even higher performance
so that's what this function is for we
define the hallmark again
we take the generator model our
discriminator model and our images
and some parameters for tuning
and we first off uh
make sure that our discriminator is not
trainable
during this uh during this
training because if we make our home and
our discriminator at the same time
drainable they will it is very hard for
one or the other to gain because if one
rises in performance the other one
automatically goes down because
it is fair yeah because it's a game
against each other
so well yeah you can see we define an
image we
take our generator model and create a
generated mask
then we let our discriminator model
decide
if this output from the generator
together with the input image
is real or fake and on that information
we then define our model
and make sure our model is trained once
again with the msc
and binary cross-entropy
i also added some code here
in how we defined
our losses um
and how we generated our real and fake
examples to
get to these losses
um yeah i'm just gonna start here so
for our real examples we're
using well just the data set we have and
we generate a real
target and a real image and a real mask
and for our
fake samples we just get a target which
has a zero
and a generated mask the
the discriminator is then trained on a
batch of these images and
resulting in a in a loss value
this also happens for the generated
examples
and also happens for the home model so
our generator loss
and to evaluate this
we use a die score and i will
give you a little insight on how that
works because
uh to train a home model it is difficult
to get to a optimal performance because
as i already explained
the as soon as the generator starts to
produce
more real images it gets harder for a
discriminator to classify if it's real
or fake
so the once gain is the other loss
so yeah you can't really come to
what they call like the nesh equivalent
where both are they optimal
uh yeah optimal performance so that's
why we're just looking at the output
images
and we're checking how much these output
these generated images
are actually overlapping with the true
masks that we have
from our data set and this works in this
way every
overlapping pixel times two
divided by all the pixels will give you
a score
so when our
generated image is exactly the same as
our true image we would get a dice score
of a hundred percent
and every uh pixel that is
off you will re this will result in a
lower die score
and with this with this die score we
were able
to get a good insight in when our model
was actually producing
the most yeah most real
mosques and and where it was for the
human eye
also very hard to see which was uh if
the
mask was generated or not and i will
come to a bit of more results
a bit later but here you can see a
little bit more it's more visualized for
what i meant
so this generator loss is going up and
down every
every other epoch and for the
discriminator losses
it's even higher i did add some
mean values so you can see that the loss
is actually
decreasing but just looking at these two
graphs it is pretty difficult to see
what what is actually happening so that
is why we
also needed the die score to see if
we're
actually training something that is
resulting in a good
good model and here you can see the
result of our
of our model we would get a around 94
percent on the validation loss which
was pretty good and the test dies of
93.6
so yeah we were we were pretty uh happy
with this result we also tested it on
different validation splits and some
different
initialization uh which all resulted in
the same results
so here you can see what we came up with
um yeah some examples of an input image
some generated mask and a true mask as
you can see
so moss has little specks where it's not
completely perfect but overall you can
see that it's doing a really well job
and but i have to say i didn't want to
leave out any bad examples so
i added one mask that was very difficult
for our model to
segment and if you're looking at the
image you
can imagine why it was hard for the
model to come up with a good mask
because even if you're looking at the
true mask it is
kind of doubtful to uh
yeah say that this is all still
part of uh yeah of the lung and this is
this is really needed for the
diagnostics and the classification
um so yeah that was our project and if
there are any questions i'm happy to
answer them yeah so thank you very much
durian so there are
a couple of questions that came through
so um one question was um so
where did you get your data from was
this given to you did you collaborate
with somebody and how big a data set did
you actually get
and i guess the hidden question is did
you have enough data to get to
meaningful results or
could you have done with more uh yeah
you can always do it more right
but no we were working with open source
data
we are still working on
providing a fruit punch
yeah open data set for for this project
and to provide it for everyone but most
of our
data are coming from kaggle
data set and we combined a few
but we also because we
we were actually dealing with very small
data sets of around
800 images with masks and
around 200 of these of these masks were
not segmented
were not segmented properly so our team
decided that it was important to enlarge
in our data set
and to uh yeah
um to improve the
masks that weren't to our liking so
eventually we had
around a thousand uh images
with bypassing
masks but this was still quite a small
data set and that's
also why we choose to work with a
conditional
adversarial network because they are
known to be
quite well performing on uh smaller
datasets
um but yeah it's so open source and
we're
still looking into it how we're gonna
publish it
and that's also a bit to the people from
fruit punch
um but yeah there's also we're working
with
right very good very good so then the
last question before we pass it on to
sako to talk about sacred
nikola is asking did you think on how to
identify those tricky examples like what
you're showing now this is a tricky one
it's very clear that it's tricky because
we're staring at it and i guess the
question is
do you have an idea or future work on
how to identify these tricky
examples well as you can see
here our mask is not really looking like
the true mask so the way that we found
this kind of mask is because they just
have the lowest die score
as i was talking right so
yeah all the images with a very low
die score we can identify them and then
decide if we want to keep them in our
data set or maybe
lose them or yeah it's a bit for the
person to decide who wants to
train the following uh covert
classification
or what other classification models
right very good very good so thank you
very much dorian so i know that uh saku
has got a cool story to tell
i know we're over time so i'm gonna ask
sakura to share
his screen um and then we'll
we'll leave some time for some questions
at the end if more people have some
so uh saku would you like to share your
screen so to just also add on
one of the questions that dorian was
just answering um
we did actually collaborate with a
medical organization called masto
who actually provided the problem and
also provided the stakeholder right
so they eventually weren't able to share
their data with it which is often a
problem with with medical uh
medical institutions they're very well
keen on their own data so that was
actually a shame
um but they did uh also guide the
project with their domain knowledge
which is actually a really important
thing right uh their view biomedical
engineers in the team here but of course
people that really know
why they would want such a solution uh
that that's key
so uh they still helped us out a lot
there
um but that's uh not uh where i'm going
to
speak on further i'm going to touch back
on this uh
gong project as well but we're now going
to look into sacred
um which has this nice slogan that says
every experiment is sacred
so what does sacred do um well it keeps
track of the parameters of any
experiment you run
it it helps you in run experiments with
different configurations
it saves the configurations of all the
runs in the database and
it's able to reproduce your results and
you might think like okay i have
many tools that can do this or maybe
written my own ones
i actually tested multiple of these
mlflow is one of the most popular ones
as
let's see at least as an open source
library and then of course you have many
data platforms that also
have some of these services like data
eco
h2o etc but i never found any of these
that were as flexible
as sacred um but i can tell you a lot
about this but it can also just show you
right and uh again gareth told me you
guys like code so
we're just going to go into that this is
a little
presentation notebook that i prepared
which is also
available on my github and this
basically goes into okay i'm going to
take the
most simple
data experiment and then build it into a
a better and better sacred experiment
right
um so what i do here first just install
sacred
uh normally you also need to we're going
to connect it to a mongodb so you would
need by [ __ ] but in this case it's
already
in the standard colab container
and and dns python is only necessary
since i use a mongodb
from uh mongol applause so the the cloud
platform of mongod
themselves which actually offer free
mongodb's of up to 512 mb
so if you want to quickly test this just
create a [ __ ] atlas account
and get a small mongodb there for free
um the test data that i'm going to use
is actually also again something that is
by default
in collab so collab always comes with
this sample data folder i actually have
no idea what this data is about but i
basically just need a numpy array to do
some experiments with so i
save uh the california housing test data
of train data set
as exampledata.netpi
and then i create my first experiment so
what i do here import
of course numpy to load the data again i
chose to do
a pca algorithm on it so i don't need to
test this and i have the
mean squared error as an accuracy
measure so first i define my model
i fit my model on the data i
decode in this case as you might know
pcc sorry sorry to interrupt you
um can you zoom in a little bit just so
that we can read the things a little bit
better
thank you so i think uh that reads a
little bit easier yeah some of us have
got high resolution screens here
thanks no that's uh that's at the time
if i need to go further just
notify me um so as you might know uh i
chose for uh
uh uh an unsupervised model here
principal component analysis which tries
to find the principal component so you
can look at it as a
like a clustering algorithm and you
first of course
trade the data you encode it and then
you try to decode it and what you check
is
what's the difference between the
encoding and the decoding right so here
we do a super simple mean squared error
apparently i did that very very badly
but that's not the point here so i have
this super simple
machine learning experiment and i have
some score there but now i need to like
okay i'm going to try different versions
of pca
are going to tune the hyper parameters
and all this kind of stuff
is going to influence this score and i
want to collect
what changes lead to what
changes in result right so this is where
sacred comes in
and to get to the most basic sacred
experiment
you just import sacred you create an
experiment give it some main
some name in this case it's an
interactive mode the only reason to do
this is because it runs in a notebook
normally
if you would just run this in pycharm or
your favorite
python id you wouldn't need to do this
well you make sure that everything is in
a function which is something that you
can basically
better do anyway and then you put this x
main
over it and that's actually just it
makes
this function the primary function for
sacred to execute
which you can then easily do by doing x
run
so what i will do then this is this is
super basic of course
it will uh and you basically what i
forgot to tell you return
uh your results at the end of the main
function
right so that's also a difference in
here i printed that
uh also what the the former speaker
told right not working uh with uh
trying to work with the function with
actually objects instead of
printing everything well here we're
doing the same thing right
um so we uh execute that and what we get
done as well so
basic output uh something that's already
very useful is that it
computes how much time it took well in
this case a secret experiment like this
takes about no time so that's
nice you can just render it really
quickly in the notebook here
of course it crashes then oh yeah sure
okay um so but this is of course still
not that useful we actually want to be
able to track
the changes not only see how long it
took well that is where the sacred
observers come in
and the first observer that we're going
to include here is a file storage
observer so the file storage observer
will basically just create
a custom path in one of your drives so
in a file path
and there it will collect some files
from the different experiments that
you're running
so in this case i just import the file
storage observer from sacred
and i append this to the observers of my
experiment
so the file storage observer in this
case only takes a base path
so a base there where all the files will
be written to
so when i now run exactly the same
experiment i also get some output files
in different paths so what we see here
is the c
out the config.json the metrics of json
and the run.json
so if you just look into what a few of
those the run.json
actually just tries to make your
experiment as reproducible as possible
not only in your own environment but
also in
environments of your co-developers right
so it takes uh
the the all the dependencies that you
have used with their versions
uh and of course the name of the
experiment
uh it even has a heartbeat a cpu
in this case i'm not using a gpu but
also the gpu it would be hosting
the exact versions of linux exact
version of python
metadata all this data that you might at
some point actually thought like oh
wouldn't have
i have liked it known if this had run on
a gpu or not on what type of gpu and
what type of operating system because
i'm not
able to debug it like this so this is
everything that it just saves by default
and of course the start time the stop
time and status in this case the
experiment is not running
anymore it has already completed and it
is also not filled
if we go into the config.json this is
quite empty
uh it only has the seed that
didn't take reduced by default and if we
uh
go to the c out uh this is actually not
created since we're in
interactive mode so it's not possible to
have a c out.txt
when you uh use interactive mode so in a
notebook
but normally this would just contain the
output of your terminal right so just
every line
as it would have ran in your terminal
will be in the c out file
so how we're going to make this even
more useful to us
well let's try and add
some other data we're going to define a
config function so
we do this by doing the x dot config
operator above it
and then defining some basic parameters
which are important
for our experiment so the path of the
data and
which model we're using then we have
just
separated the part where we load in the
data into a separate function
and we capture that as part of the uh
experiment of
as part of the the sacred experiment so
of course you don't need to do this
right you could basically also run
this function without the making it part
of the sacred scope but the nice thing
about sacred
is that every parameter that you define
in the config
will actually become a kind of global
variable
which you can then inject in any of
these functions so i don't need to pass
the data path into the data function
down here and therefore also i don't
need to pass it to the train data
i can just uh do this x capture make the
data function part of the sacred scope
and then do import this this
config parameter in the definition of
the
the function so here again exactly the
same experiment and we would get the
same
output files here nothing that new here
except
that we now have defined a config and
therefore there will
also be information in the config.json
so beside the seed we now have of course
the data path
but also the object that i defined so
the pca
with all the parameters in there which
again if i'm going to do hyperparameter
optimization is very useful
to have all the hyper parameters so not
only the ones that i
set specifically but actually all the
parameters that the pca object catches
in here in the config file
so uh at some point you don't only want
uh
to uh record the basic result right as
we saw before i
uh print this uh basic result and it's
also saved into the
uh into the config file but we want to
say for example uh the model itself
well there are a few ways of doing this
one of those is adding it
as a an artifact so what i did here is i
added one function which is
just a simple function to pickle an
object
this is not part of the sacred scope
since it will not
use any of the conflict parameters but
what it will do
is at some point it will ask itself okay
do i want to save this model and
to add this artifact i add the trained
pca model as an artifact so what we
would get done
after running again same experiment we
would be able oh and
besides that i also appended
the scores of a csv here and also added
that one to the
artifact what we would get that is not
only the
c out config and the metrics under
json but also this pickled file would be
added to the same folder
and to the same score so now all we've
seen
is using the file observer which is
really nice of course but
it's also super limiting so if i'm
writing all this to my local hard drive
i can't share it with my fellow
developers
but also it's really hard to query right
what if i want to do
cross validation so i want to run 20
experiments and i want to
see if my accuracies are stable or i
want to compare a few experiments i
would need to
write additional code to extract this
from these json files and these
txt files so of course that's not
the way to go the way to go is actually
adding the [ __ ] server so as i
mentioned before it's really easy to
create a small
mongodb using the outlast platform of
mongodb itself
and here we then have one including the
[ __ ] server actually always make sure
to
uh catch that behind the debug folder
you often just
write an experiment make some changes
run the experiment and apparently you
made some error
in writing the calculation of the metric
so your whole experiment crashes while
it had run for two hours
well that's a shame anyway so i should
have written better testing code
but anyhow also when this happens you
don't want it to
clutter your mongodb so in that case i
always just set a flag
to debug it and then not write into the
mobility
here you see my [ __ ] credentials i'm
sure some of you have noticed
this account will delete itself tomorrow
so i don't i'm not really worrying about
it
but it is actually functional code right
so it will
right now connect to the database
oh it's not definitely not doing that
i haven't run all this code
i guess i should do that
and but anyhow
also here we see the same functions that
we saw before right the config
the data the main nothing there is
changing
what is changing oh it missed the
typical
function yeah it's there now no it's not
there now
where did it find it here
ah
live demos always dangerous and i'm not
a
swift as a coder as uh the guy before me
so
but um here we define exactly the same
functions
uh only we uh now have this extra
observer here right so the all of the
code is the same as in the previous cell
but we just decided to add an extra
observer the mobile observer which just
has the authentication
url and the name of the database where i
want this code to
where i want these artifacts to be
written to
so now besides having this data
structure in my local drive
i also have it in a mongodb somewhere in
the cloud
and i'm just going to show you in a sec
how you can extract that of course but
as you all know uh you can query mongodb
really easily it's basically working
with
python dictionaries so it should be
really uh
usable for anyone who is very familiar
with using python
and this way you can just query all
these different experiments and see
hey how how have i been doing over time
create nice reports based on the live
experiments that you are
running right now all these things are
possible when you simply add
this basically one line of code to your
secret experiment just to give you an
example of a bit more complex
experiment here you have a simple keras
auto encoder
and there you would have some of the
same code like do i want to
save the model and save the tensorboard
the reason that i don't do this on
debugging of course is that uh
neural network would become way larger
and would start to clutter my database
and would start to clutter
my hard drive the same holds for
tensorboard files which can become
really large
so i only want to create those when i
actually am running an actual experiment
this also changes in this case the
observer path so where it is writing the
the experiment numbers and from there we
have
a configuration which now holds things
like batch size and coding dimensions
number of ebooks
ebooks that i want to run the experiment
i have a data
set where in this case i just create two
data generators a training and a
validation generator which i can return
here
and that takes these global variables
those
well the the sacred global variables for
a database size
then i define a model function here it
takes the encoding dim and a bad size
and just creates a really simple
encoder decoder model and then i have an
auto main in this case uh which would
mean that i don't have to x run at the
end of the code it's just
make sure that it runs this code the
moment that you run
the experiment file
here just what you would expect when
running any terrace
model compiling it uh adding uh
callbacks like the tensorboard
fitting the generator and then uh
optionally
saving the model getting all the results
from the history of keras and then
returning those results at the end of
the main function right
so there this one doesn't run but the
one that would run
is this one and it's the
connect oh connect with gpu
so as you guys probably know
[Music]
if you use a collab you can actually use
them with free gpus in there so if you
in the runtime you change runtime type
you can set it to gpu here
so in this case run anyway
i first have to
sorry what is wrong
oh i've used too much gpu today
that's very very sad well i don't per
say have to run the code
so that's not that bad no no live
experiments anymore that's sad for you
guys so i can't screw up
um but here we mount a drive where we
actually
host the data set so it will ask for
some authentication here
again we install sacred and dns python
all the other packages that we need are
already in the collab
environment normally we would get a
tesla
t4 gpu but in this case it has denied us
any access on that
um so from here we do the importing of
all the packages
and this is actually the code that
dorian
showed you just now but then in the form
of a sacred experiment right so indeed
again
we have this defining an experiment we
have the conflict in this
case a way more complicated one than you
would have if you just define a simple
pca algorithm so we have all the
the losses all the parameters here that
dorian already explained to you
um here we configured our observer so
again we have this [ __ ] observer and we
have the
the file path observer this again
by the way also just written directly
back to a google drive
on the collab connection
we load the real samples we get the
names these are all sacred functions and
we don't
and again we keep clean code since we
don't have to pass all these parameters
here we just give them to
the function via the the configuration
of
sacred these you might recognize
the bits of code that durian showed
before so the definition of the
generators etc the compilation of the
gan
all these are part of the sacred
environment
and in the end we would get to the main
function
and here we start training the model so
we actually
set the seeds so if you remember there
was a seed in the config file if you
want to use this seeds you can just do
underscore seed
in any function in this case we want to
set that to the same as the basic python
sheet and the tensorflow seed
to make sure that our model is actually
reproducible right so that's also a main
reason to use sacred reload the data set
do all the things that you expect to
that you do when you try to train a
neural network
calculate the losses uh
this is the code that uh dorian also
showed you we're doing some early
stopping here based on the dice
metric and at the end we collect the
result so we see okay which epoch we
yielded the best laws and what was this
loss
but of course we also just want to have
all the losses
uh over time right so the standard
deviations of those with the train and
the validation
as well and where did we save our model
as a useful information
so this is all run through a sacred
experiment this is what you would see
during the running of it so
you this case this was experiment 20
already
for this specific uh version and here
it was able to get the best file loss
from epoch 5.
so if we then go over here here is
well the simple craft that durian showed
as well what you want to do then of
course
is now all this information is in the
mongodb so all the information
all the files that i showed you before
are here again i got
this disconnected i specifically did
reconnected them all just before the
meeting started but apparently
that's too long ago um so the nice thing
here is in a completely different
environment so this is a new golab file
which is not connected to the other one
at all in any way here i also do not
make this connection to uh
to my google drive so it's a completely
standalone environment
but i of course connect to the same
mongodb there's just some
super basic code helping me to
extract the results from that
which all of you would know if you have
the basic uh
fighting skills and this is actually
what inside
what is inside a rod so here i didn't
have any artifacts
but again we have the config right so
all the bad sizes all the config
parameters that you saw before will be
in here and are all
uh variable in this dictionary
you can see the main part the number of
epochs again the versions of all the
libraries
here you see that this time i was able
to use when i ran this experiment i was
able to use a gpu i got a tesla k80 from
collab
i even got the host name of the the the
collab system and the python versions
etc that it ran
and then of course the results right
which result was the best in this case
that was epoch zero
uh i only ran it for one epoch so that's
not too weird
and these are the losses that are
collected here
this is just some simple code that is
going over all the experiments that i've
run so far
at least the first until 25th experiment
and it will try to see which one did
finish so as you can see
i screwed up 17 experiments by
writing bad code so all of those crashed
but the next four experiments up until
number
21 did actually succeed and then you can
just start
querying those so if i want to get the
first of those
this would be experiment
19 here you get again this this
dictionary back
and you can just start querying that and
also collecting
concatenating that data right so that's
the goal of doing it in a mongodb
concatenating all this data making
reports and
this becomes really a lot easier for you
and your
team to collaborate on building
experiments making sure they're
reproducible
and actually comparing their results um
so that's actually about it and that's
what i wanted to tell you guys about
sacred so sosaku this is very very very
interesting
um maybe you can uh
answer a few questions that came through
the the system while we're here so
question number one
was um this seems like a bit of overhead
for a data scientist right so
you know it feels like uh you're
diverging from the essence of the math
there the question really is how hard is
it for someone who's a
pure data scientist to pick up this and
use it right so you articulated that
there's value
if you use it but it has to be used
right and the question is how hard is
this to be picked up by others
well i don't know um whom here
has been like a junior data scientist
and then
at some point was doing exactly what you
just now say just now of me writing
experiments
changing hyper parameters and at some
point thinking like
damn i'm sure that i got a higher
accuracy some time ago but i have no
idea how i configured that and then
looking back at your emails trying to
find
if you maybe email the code to someone
uh you didn't use git
properly uh uh damn oh wait
you know what i'm going to write some
custom python cards to do this right i'm
going to write some code that writes
accuracy to a txt file that's going to
help
you okay i'm doing that two weeks later
you have exactly the same problem but
you uh
don't remember if you ran it on the
linux kernel or on windows and you have
some bugs that might have caused that
oh how did i do it again starting to
write this
own custom python code to try and record
all this data
well uh as i showed you before making us
a secret exp making an experiment into a
sacred experiment
just uh needs four lines of code
it's really easy for anybody to use so
of course if you want to go into the
mongodb
and you want to query that etc you maybe
need a bit more of the computer science
skills
than you would as a pure data scientist
but just adding the sacred code
and being able to at least look back
into the file observer and see like okay
this is how i ran that experiment back
then
this will also save you so much time in
reiterating
these experiments and in that sense also
saving computational power
saving the environment by using less
power there's only
advantages here so that's very good so
so thank you very much for that and it's
nice that you showed it to the example
the durian showed you connected the dot
so thank you for that
then the last question before we call it
a day is
um you showed a lot of code and
unfortunately some of us couldn't follow
the code at the pace that you were
talking
the question is how can we see this will
you share some of the links is this
something that
we could dive in at a later stage would
this be something that you could share
afterwards
and if so uh what would your
recommendation be on the youtube
comments of pi data talk would that be
all right the right place to do it
oh yeah i could paste it in there where
you can already find it
is the at least the first notebook that
i showed you so the one where i
change this pca experiment into a more
and more complex sacred experiment
that's actually on my github which is a
cycle of arts
concatenated and also by going to
uh psychoarts.net sacred you actually
will end up on the
github page so you can just really see
how you can step by step make this uh
uh i'll just type it into the so so that
the chat that you're typing only the
presenters can see so we will we will
share that later
but maybe just one last question is and
this actually is a good one i should
have thought it myself is
it you're showing the parameters but the
sacred also store the code that was used
so i think you only showed it stores
parameters and incremental things but
does it also store the code or is that
yeah again how is that coupled to each
other how does that work
if you go to it to the the notebook that
i also
that i'm going to share that's actually
in the text there this is again a
limitation of the interactive mode
but indeed if you uh run it as a normal
python file and then use
don't use the interactive mode then it
will save
all the code of all the experimentation
code into a source file
in the same folder where it leaves all
the other stuff and of course then also
in the database
that's very nice so i guess that comes
to the point of why you said this is
more flexible than some of the other
solutions that you saw
this is maybe a good example where it
speaks to it so with that being said i
want to thank you ever so much